[MUSIC PLAYING]
RORY TRUEX: I study
Chinese politics
and I teach courses
on Chinese politics,
so I am grateful for
this opportunity today
to get to speak to you
about events unfolding
in China this past year.
So often, when we
talk about China,
we talk about it through the
lens of China-US, the trade
war, these sorts of things.
But actually, in mainland
China in domestic politics,
this has been a seminal year,
in part because of this man--
Xi Jinping.
And so today, I wanted
to really just focus
on giving you a briefing.
I thought that would be
the most helpful thing.
I'd like to give you
a sense of what's
unfolding this past year,
and what we can think
will happen moving forward.
So, I wanted to
start-- as I mentioned,
I teach courses on
Chinese politics,
so I wanted to start with an
exam question, which I can see,
there was little
enthusiasm for that.
But here we go.
Bear with me.
So this past fall, I taught
a course on Chinese politics.
And for the final exam,
I asked the students
to identify a year, a critical
year in the development
of China, in particular, of
China's political development.
So we have this concept
in political science,
something called a
critical juncture,
which is a jargony way of
saying that is a turning
point, a year where
certain events unfolded
and certain decisions
were made that changed
the trajectory of history.
And so if we look
back at the last 70
years of the rule of the
Chinese Communist Party,
certain years come
quickly to mind,
which I'm sure many of
you are familiar with.
The first is, of course, 1949.
1949 is the establishment of
the People's Republic of China.
This is a picture of
Mao Zedong standing
in Tiananmen Square
declaring the establishment
of the People's Republic.
And for the first
time in decades,
the territory of
mainland China is
consolidated under the rule
of a single government.
So this was a heady
time for China,
and signaling the
beginning of Mao's rule.
Another year which
is, of course,
very important is 1978, the
beginning of so-called reform
and opening-up.
Does anybody here speak
Chinese or study Chinese?
So I remember when I
started taking Chinese,
I took Chinese 101.
And one of the first
words we learned
is [SPEAKING CHINESE],, which
means "reform and opening-up."
And I swear, 50%
of our lessons were
about reform and opening-up.
So it's an important year.
And for those of you who
are less familiar with it,
this signals the beginning
of China's economic miracle.
So Deng Xiaoping
comes into power
and takes a much more
pragmatic stance with respect
to economic policy-making,
basically undoes
the command part of
the Chinese economy,
and results in an
influx of trade
and foreign direct investment
in the so-called 30 years
of 10% economic growth.
This is the beginning
of this era.
This is him visiting the US,
and he's wearing a cowboy hat.
This is one of the famous
images of reform and opening-up.
Another year is,
of course, 1989.
1989 is the year of
the Tiananmen Square
movement and the
Tiananmen Square Massacre.
And this is the year where
we learned that the Communist
Party was willing to do whatever
it took to stay in power
and was not amenable to the
idea of political reform.
And this is the
year where we saw
them willing to use live
ammunition on student
protesters.
And finally, what I'm
going to argue today--
and I'm starting to come
up with this argument.
It's not fully developed.
But what I argue is that,
potentially, 2017 and 2018
have the capacity to
be one of those years.
So it's difficult to know.
We haven't seen history
unfold quite yet.
We haven't seen the
trajectory moving forward.
But there have been a number
of developments in the last 12
months that signal
this might be a turning
point for contemporary China.
In particular, this
is the year where
Xi Jinping, the current General
Secretary of the Chinese
Communist Party, has
fully consolidated
his power, signaled
the start of a new era
under his rule that
could last well
beyond his expected
time in power.
So today, I want to
give you a briefing
as to what happened this past
year, why I think this might be
a critical year, and then some
trends to think about moving
forward, some things that might
be worth paying attention to.
So before I get into
what happened this year,
I want to set the stage to
talk a little bit about how
we used to talk about China.
And when I say "how we," I mean
mostly the political scientist
community.
And when I say "used to,"
I mean not that long ago.
I mean only a few years ago.
We used to describe
the Chinese Communist
Party through the lens of
almost an exceptionalism.
So most authoritarian regimes--
and the Chinese Communist Party
is an authoritarian regime--
they don't last very long.
They live short, brutish,
violent existences,
and they fall from a number
of different threats.
The two most pressing threats
facing any authoritarian leader
are the threat from within,
the threat of a coup attempt--
actually, there's
some data on this
from Milan Svolik, who is a
political scientist at Yale.
And he actually shows that
most authoritarian regimes
die in this way.
They crumble from within.
I think it's roughly 60% to 70%
of authoritarian regimes fall
via coup, where one leader comes
in and basically institutes
a new authoritarian regime.
And then the second
way they fall
is through the
threat of revolution.
This is the more
romantic version
of how authoritarian
regimes collapse.
The population comes together,
demands political reform,
and either through
some violent struggle
or some brokered transition,
the authoritarian regime
falls and is replaced
with something
else-- hopefully democracy.
So these are the
two problems facing
any authoritarian
leader, including
Xi Jinping, Hu Jintao, Jiang
Zemin, and all the way on back.
And the way we used
to describe the party
was, wow, this is
a regime that seems
to have learned from
the lessons of history
and figured out how to
mitigate some of these issues.
So in particular,
the key feature
of the authoritarian regime in
China was institutionalization.
So one of the difficulties
for any authoritarian regime
is how to share power,
how to keep elites happy,
how to transfer power from
one leader to another.
So if we look back in the
2000s, there were a set
of institutions--
rules and norms--
that the Communist
Party had developed
that seemed to be solving this
dilemma of threats from within.
So in particular,
there was a norm
that no leader would stay in
office longer than 10 years.
So leaders at the very
top, including Xi Jinping,
were expected to stay in
office for two five-year terms.
The successor would be
anointed in advance--
usually five years in advance,
potentially earlier than that--
thus smoothing the
power transition,
allowing that person to
develop cache within the system
and experience.
There would be well-established
retirement ages,
so people would be
forced to leave office
and wouldn't hang on too long.
Power was exercised
not by just one person,
but collectively, where
each leader at the top--
and when I say the
top, I generally
am referring to what's known
as the Politburo Standing
Committee, the top tier of
leadership of the Chinese
Communist Party, usually
seven to nine leaders.
Each leader would be
given a portfolio.
And while there would be
one most senior leader,
they would cooperate
with each other.
They would play nice.
So these were the
key institutions
that we look back on under
Jiang Zemin and Hu Jintao,
the two predecessors
of Xi Jinping,
and we say these institutions
contributed to the resilience
of the Communist Party.
So that's the
threat from within.
The threat from
below-- revolution--
the Communist Party is
an authoritarian regime.
It uses the language
of democracy
and claims to be democratic,
but no self-respecting political
scientist would call the Chinese
Communist Party democratic.
But nevertheless,
in the 2000s, it
looked like the party was
starting to develop mechanisms
for citizens to have a voice.
So these weren't democratic.
They were tightly
controlled by the party.
But nevertheless, there were
channels through which citizens
could voice their concerns.
This is everything
from a petition system,
village elections, a People's
Congress system, which
is their legislative system,
online public opinion
portals, mayor's mailboxes.
It's getting increasingly
online and digital.
But there were
channels in place where
citizens could funnel
their grievances
and the party could respond.
And so some of the language
we used to describe
the party at this time was--
we used to call it
responsive authoritarianism
or consultative
authoritarianism.
In general, this is
a more tolerable form
of authoritarian regime.
This wasn't a
tinpot dictatorship.
This was a regime that
was sophisticated,
and institutionalized,
and seemed to be trying
to mitigate these issues.
So that's how we
used to describe it.
And this argument-- I
should cite the author.
His name's Andrew Nathan.
This was made in 2003 if any of
you want to do further reading.
I'm sure you have
plenty of other things
to do with your
time, but the article
is called "Authoritarian
Resilience."
So enter Xi Jinping.
So Xi Jinping is the
current General Secretary
of the Communist Party.
So I'm afraid I'm
going to have to get
in a little bit
of the weeds here
in terms of the Chinese
leadership system,
but bear with me.
So any top leader of
China today actually
has three different positions.
So the first is that
they're General Secretary
of the Chinese Communist Party.
That's the head of the party.
That's the most
important position.
They are also de facto President
of the People's Republic
of China, which is the head of
state, the government position.
The party and the government
on paper are separate things.
In reality, they're
heavily intertwined
and the party dominates
the government.
And actually, in my experience,
many Chinese citizens
have trouble differentiating
the party institutions
and the party positions from
the government positions.
But Xi Jinping's party
position is General Secretary.
His government position
is the president.
And he also has a
military position.
He's chair of what's known
as the Central Military
Commission.
So he's head of state, head
of party, head of military.
So he assumed these
positions in 2012,
and we are just finishing
up his first term in office.
And therefore, he's expected
to retire in 2022-2023.
Now prior to coming to office--
I just want to emphasize
a couple of things
about Xi Jinping's rise.
The first is, like
many Chinese leaders,
you might hear of this
so-called China model, this idea
that China is a
meritocratic system
and people are promoted based
on their abilities, and talents,
and experience, and so forth.
That is a highly controversial
argument to make.
What I would say
is that Xi Jinping,
like many other
Chinese leaders, had
a lot of governing experience
upon entering his highest
position.
So he rose up the
ranks from a young age,
was party secretary
and mayor and governor
of various different
parts of China,
was involved in the
Central Party School.
He actually helped run
the Beijing Olympics.
So by the time he became
General Secretary,
he was highly experienced.
The second feature
of his rise is
that he is what's
known as a princeling.
So in Chinese
politics, a princeling
is simply a leader whose
father or grandfather-- and I
apologize for using
male nouns here,
but this is empirically true.
Almost all Chinese
leaders are male.
A princeling is a Chinese leader
whose father or grandfather
was also a leader.
And so Xi Jinping's
father's name
is Xi Zhongxun, who actually
worked with Mao Zedong
before being purged during
the Cultural Revolution.
But Xi Jinping, because of
this princeling status--
an American princeling would be
like Chelsea Clinton and George
W. Bush.
That's how you can
draw the connection.
Because of this
princeling status,
he potentially had a
more accelerated rise,
and he had a certain level
of prestige within the system
early on.
And then the third thing I
would talk about about his rise
is that, like many Chinese
leaders, prior to him
coming to power, we actually
didn't know a lot about him.
So one way to rise up
through the Chinese system
seems to be to keep
your head down,
to develop relationships
with patrons
who are higher in
office than you,
and not take any dramatic policy
stances in either direction.
So prior to coming
into office, we really
didn't know a lot about what
Xi Jinping was all about.
And if you look back at some
of the discourse about him
in 2012 and 2013,
a lot of people
believed he was
China's Gorbachev.
So this is a
democrat in waiting.
He's going to be
the one who finally
liberalizes China and
embarks on political reform.
And the basis for these
claims was, in retrospect,
fairly weak.
Xi Jinping spent time in Iowa.
This is him as a younger man.
He spent time in Iowa
on an exchange program.
So he spent time in Iowa.
His daughter attends
Harvard University.
Therefore, he must get it.
He must be a liberal.
As it turns out, this conjecture
couldn't have been further
from the truth.
Xi Jinping is a reformer.
And I'll talk more
about that later.
But he is a reformer
of the illiberal sort.
So he's moving China in a more
authoritarian direction, not
a more democratic direction.
So what happened in 2017-2018?
Why is this past 12
months such a big deal?
Well, there were
really three events
that unfolded that really
changed what we thought
we knew about Chinese politics.
The first occurred at what's
known as the Party Congress.
The Party Congress
occurred last fall.
It's a meeting of the 2,000 most
powerful members of the Chinese
Communist Party.
It happens only once
every five years.
And during this
event, we typically
see the unveiling of
new leadership circles.
And what we were expecting
to see, based on precedent,
was that Xi Jinping--
there would be a new group
of top seven leaders--
Xi Jinping would still be in
power because he still has one
five-year term left--
but that there would
be a successor.
So we would see
two new leaders put
into the top tier of the
Chinese Communist Party,
and it would be generally
understood, potentially even
announced, that these
people were going
to take over from Xi Jinping.
There would be a new
successor in waiting.
So first thing we
learned this fall
is that there actually-- when
this new leader-- this is
the event, this image
that I'm showing here.
That's actually four out
of the new seven members
of the Politburo
Standing Committee.
There was no
successor announced.
So remember, I talked
about institutions.
This is a big one, having a
successor named in advance.
That one's gone.
And why is this a big deal?
Well, actually, basically since
the Tiananmen Square Massacre,
the Tiananmen Square
incident, there
has been a successor in place
in the Chinese political system.
So it was known that Jiang
Zemin would transfer power
to Hu Jintao.
Xi Jinping came to office in
the Politburo Standing Committee
in 2007.
It was known that he would
take over for Hu Jintao.
So now, for the
first time, we don't
have a successor, which means
this can generate instability.
So if an authoritarian regime--
we don't know.
If something ever
happened to Xi Jinping,
if he had a health problem
or something like this,
there would be a major
public power struggle.
So that was the
event number one.
Event number two is a
little more into the weeds,
but I thought we could
have some fun with it.
So this is event number two.
And I had to write
it down because I
have trouble remembering
all of the language.
But I encourage you
all to memorize this--
"Xi Jinping Thought on Socialism
with Chinese Characteristics
for the New Era."
This is a mouthful.
I am not a native
speaker of Chinese,
and my Chinese is probably
suspect, but [SPEAKING CHINESE]
That's it in Chinese.
To me, it also sounds like
a mouthful in Chinese.
There are native Chinese
speakers in the room.
I heard you before, so maybe
you can tell me if you agree.
But another feature of the
Chinese political system
is that any elite
leader is expected
to make an ideological
contribution to the Communist
Party doctrine.
So every leader has
their pet phrase.
Mao Zedong has Mao
Zedong Thought.
Deng Xiaoping has
Deng Xiaoping Theory.
Jiang Zemin's contribution is
known as The Three Represents.
It should be said that it's
not called Jiang Zemin's Three
Represents.
It's just called The
Three Represents.
Scientific Concept of
Development is Hu Jintao.
And so now, Xi
Jinping's contribution
is known as Xi Jinping
Thought on Socialism
with Chinese Characteristics
for the New Era.
This phrase was put
into the Constitution,
the charter of the
Communist Party itself.
And it was done so while
Xi Jinping was still
in office, still in power.
Usually, it happens
after the fact.
So if we dissect this phrase,
a few things stand out.
First, Xi Jinping--
his name is in it.
So it's a named phrase.
This honor had only been
reserved for Mao Zedong
and Deng Xiaoping.
So here we have Xi
Jinping placing himself
on par with those two leaders.
The second word I want
you to pay attention to is
"thought," [SPEAKING CHINESE].
So remember, there's Mao Zedong
Thought and Deng Xiaoping
Theory.
So there are some analysts who
believe that a thought actually
is higher than a theory.
Well, now, we're
getting into semantics.
But it's telling that Mao
Zedong had Mao Zedong Thought.
So now we have Xi Jinping
Thought, Mao Zedong Thought.
So not only is he
putting himself
on par with Mao and Deng, he
may be only putting himself
on par with Mao and above Deng.
Socialism with Chinese
characteristics
is an old, tired phrase in
Communist Party ideology.
It's basically their way
of justifying the fact
that they've gone a market
direction while still
using socialist language.
So this is actually
not a new phrase.
But the last thing that I
think is, in some sense,
the most important
is the New Era.
So Xi Jinping is declaring
that we are in a new era,
and he is at the center.
And up until this
point, we have generally
thought that China was in
the so-called reform period.
So beginning in 1978, we have
the reform and opening-up.
That was the period we were in.
Xi Jinping is saying we are
in the end of that period.
We are in a new era,
and I am at the center.
So that was event number two.
Event number three
occurred this past March,
where we had an amendment
to China's constitution
that got rid of term limits for
the position of the presidency.
So prior to this, the
position of the presidency,
which, you remember, is Xi
Jinping's government position,
was governed by two
five-year term limits.
And this past spring,
which, honestly,
would have been unbelievable
five or 10 years ago--
that term limit was
gotten away with.
So the interpretation
of all of these events--
so again, just to reiterate,
so we have no successor,
we have Xi Jinping Thought
in the Constitution,
and now we have no term limits.
The interpretation among
the China studies community
and the China
watcher community is
that this signals that
Xi Jinping is potentially
trying to stay on past
his expected retirement
in 2022, the
so-called Xi for life.
And I titled the
talk not Xi For Life,
I titled it "Xi For Life?"
with a question mark
at the end of it
because I think it's
important for us
all to remember
that what we know
about elite politics in China
is actually quite little.
It's an extremely opaque system.
And so people that
observe the system,
we're left to take
these very crude signals
and try to infer what's going
on between the party leaders
and what's going
on in their heads.
And so I think it's a
bit premature to say oh,
he'll be in there for
the rest of his life.
Although Donald Trump actually
congratulated him on being--
[LAUGHTER]
I went 20 minutes without
bringing up Donald Trump.
So my own interpretation--
so one possibility,
he is intending to stay on.
That's one possibility.
A second possibility is
he is using these moves
to further consolidate power
and create uncertainty.
So one feature of the
Chinese political system
is if you anoint a
successor, you actually
are creating a rival, and you're
creating a new base of power.
And instantly, that person who
is the successor in waiting
becomes quite
powerful, and you're
a lame duck for five years.
And so maybe by not
anointing a successor
and signaling that he
might want to stay,
he's just maintaining his
own bargaining leverage.
So that's one other
interpretation
that I think is
important to think about.
Either way, my own feeling
is that whether or not
he stays in office or
retires, it actually
doesn't matter as
much as you might
think because if he does
install a successor,
he will likely try to
install a lackey of his own.
So he will install someone
who is loyal to him,
and he will rule from
behind the scenes.
And this is also common
in the Chinese system.
Deng Xiaoping continued to rule
despite not actually having
the highest level title.
So power in the Chinese system
is in some sense about titles,
and in many others,
it's actually
about personal relationships
within the system.
So either way, I
think one takeaway
I want you to come away
with from the talk today
is that we are likely in an
era where Xi Jinping is going
to be at the center of the
Chinese political system not
just for the next five years,
but likely for the next 10, 15,
possibly even 20 years.
Of course, it's
difficult to predict.
So what do we know
about Xi Jinping?
So if we're in his era--
we've gotten a
chance to watch him
in office now for five years.
So what is he actually about?
What does he care about?
What makes him tick?
If I had to describe
him in three words,
I would use the following.
I would say he's nationalist,
he is authoritarian,
and he's populist,
that combination.
So nationalism-- one of the key
phrases of Xi Jinping Thought--
and I encourage you to go
study Xi Jinping Thought--
is this idea of the so-called
China Dream or Chinese Dream
depending on how you
see it translated--
[SPEAKING CHINESE] in Chinese.
The Chinese Dream
dates back to this idea
of national rejuvenation.
There is a narrative in the
Chinese political system
that China was once
a great nation.
That status was robbed of it
by foreign imperialist powers,
beginning with the Opium War.
There is a century
of humiliation
where China is
repeatedly infringed
upon by foreign powers.
And only when the
Chinese Communist Party
comes to power in 1949,
that's the establishment
of a new China, and
China has stood up.
And so Xi Jinping's
China Dream is
an extension of that narrative.
And the basic dream, as
it has been articulated,
is that China will once again
become a strong, powerful,
and prosperous nation.
One of the most cliche things
you can say about China
is that it is a
collectivist culture.
This is a pet peeve of mine.
It's a very simplistic
way of thinking,
and it's, in some sense,
an orientalist way
of describing China.
But in this instance,
I think it's
important to emphasize
that this China Dream--
Americans hear this,
and they think, oh,
that's the American dream.
That sounds pretty good.
It's actually quite distinct.
So this is an image of
one of the propaganda
posters of the China Dream.
And you'll see, in
Chinese, it says,
[SPEAKING CHINESE], China Dream.
And under it,
[SPEAKING CHINESE],,
means my dream.
So we literally have the
individual being placed
subservient to the nation.
And to be working
under the China Dream,
for an individual
Chinese citizen,
it's about achieving
the collective goal
of national rejuvenation.
So this isn't about I'm going
to work hard and better myself
like the American dream.
This is a collective dream.
This nationalism has been
ramped up in recent years.
And it seems to me that
increasingly, the party
is relying on nationalism
as a source of legitimacy.
So under the Mao era, the source
of legitimacy was ideology
and Mao himself.
Under the reform period,
under Deng Xiaoping
and his successors, the source
of legitimacy was performance.
So we are going
to deliver goods--
economic growth, public good
provision, and so forth.
Now, economic growth
is slowing in China.
It's down to roughly 6%.
And so a new source
of legitimacy, it
seems that nationalism
will be the source of that.
And we see Xi Jinping being
increasingly assertive
on the international stage.
You might have heard
about the South China Sea,
China's territorial claims
there, his willingness
to build islands and install
military installations
on those islands to
buttress territorial claims.
China's growing increasingly
aggressive with respect
to Taiwan and
reunification with Taiwan.
You might have heard of the
One Belt, One Road Initiative,
or the Belt and Road Initiative.
It's constantly rebranded.
But this is so-called
China's Marshall Plan.
It will be a multibillion
dollar investment
project spanning
multiple countries
and multiple continents.
So we have a nationalistic,
assertive Xi Jinping.
The second adjective I use to
describe him is authoritarian.
China always has these cycles.
If you look at the long
arc of Chinese history,
there are ups and downs.
There are periods of opening
and periods of closing.
Mao Zedong comes to power,
and we see a closing
with the Great Leap Forward
and the Culture Revolution.
Deng Xiaoping comes
to power, and we
see an opening, where
political discourse has
liberalized a little bit.
Then we have Tiananmen
Square Massacre, a closing.
Then actually, if we
look back at the 2000s,
we didn't maybe
realize it at the time,
but that was a period
of relative openness
in Chinese society.
Under Xi Jinping,
we have entered
into another closed period.
And I would argue--
and I don't think
I'm alone in this--
that China today
is the most repressive
it's been since the period
just following the
Tiananmen Square Incident.
And this has manifested
itself in a lot of ways.
There's increasing control among
civil society organizations.
One of the key tenants
of Xi Jinping Thought
is that party should dominate
all aspects of society.
We also see the party
willing to use good,
old-fashioned
repression, detentions,
torture, intimidation to
groups that it doesn't like.
This is an image of Li Wenzu.
She is the wife of the
man in that picture
there, Wang Quanzhang,
who is what's
known as a Weiquan lawyer.
The Weiquan lawyers in China--
Weiquan just means
rights protection.
These are effectively
public defenders.
They are a group of lawyers
who are civic-minded,
and have tried to use the
principles of the Chinese
constitution-- which is actually
quite liberal on paper--
to help Chinese citizens protect
themselves from the government.
So they take cases on
everything from labor issues,
environmental issues,
property rights protection,
so people who have had
their property demolished
by the Chinese government.
So these are people
that are trying
to work on behalf
of the population,
and to protect them from
the government using
the Constitution.
So they're not
radicals, actually.
They're not
advocating revolution.
Most of them are advocating
that the government
abide by constitutionalism
and rule of law.
Today, in China,
such individuals
to be this type of lawyer
has become a crime,
and hundreds of them
have been detained.
This particular
individual, Wang Quanzhang,
was detained for three
years without any meeting
with his lawyer.
There's a certain irony in that.
Not allowed to meet his family.
We just found out last week
that he is still alive,
but I was at an event two
weeks ago where his wife spoke,
and she was unclear
whether he was still alive.
So it's important to
keep talking about this.
I think a lot of us, when we
go to China-- myself included--
you get there, and you
think, oh, this isn't so bad.
Really, it's not
that bad at all.
It seems pretty normal here.
And that's on purpose.
And a lot of the repression
hums along in the background,
and it's easy to overlook it.
And it doesn't affect
most of the population.
But for those individuals
that do try to advocate things
like human rights
and political reform,
the regime is willing to
do the dirty business.
So Xi Jinping is authoritarian.
He is nationalistic.
And the final thing I
would say is he's populist.
So one of the
hallmarks of his rule
which you might have heard of
is the anti-corruption campaign.
So Xi Jinping came to office,
and he was quite different
from his predecessors.
He had a little charisma.
Hu Jintao was known as
being a bland technocrat.
Xi Jinping, upon
coming into office,
he went to a steamed
bun shop in Beijing,
ate with normal people.
He fosters this image
as a man of the people.
And one of the key
features of his rule
has been cracking
down on corruption.
And corruption in China
was the main threat
to the survival of the
Chinese Communist Party.
So if you look at
survey data in China,
corruption was always ranked
as the number one or number two
issue among the
Chinese population.
The levels of corruption
were quite high.
This is a feature of
an authoritarian system
with no electoral
accountability, no freedom
of the press, a lack of
civil society organizations,
undergoing the process where
business assets are being
gone from public to private.
So this is a recipe
for corruption.
So Xi Jinping comes to power.
And immediately, we see a
crackdown on so-called tigers
and flies.
Tigers are senior
levels of officials
within the Chinese system.
So he's willing to go
after the big officials.
And then if you're a
lower-level official in China,
you're called a
fly, which is tough.
Maybe one day you'll
grow up to be a tiger,
but for now, you're a fly.
So Xi Jinping's
anti-corruption campaign
signals his willingness to
tackle the tough issues.
The interpretation
about this campaign--
there are really two
that you'll hear.
The first is that this is
all just a political ploy
to purge his enemies.
And I believe there
is some truth to that.
If you look at the highest
levels of the Chinese Communist
Party, individuals who have
been investigated invariably
are not in Xi Jinping's
personal clique.
They are people who are in
the rival faction or people
who might be opposed to him.
That said, the
other interpretation
is that this is a genuine
effort at cleaning up the party.
And if you go to China and
you talk to individuals,
there is some optimism that
Xi Jinping is a strong leader,
he's a competent
leader, and he's
the one that is going
to clean up the party.
I think there's some
truth to both narratives.
If he's investigated hundreds
of thousands of individuals,
I have trouble believing
that all of this
is politically motivated.
I do think there is some genuine
anti-corruption behavior going
on.
But it's important not to be
too rosy about this development,
in the sense that
actually fighting
corruption is
difficult, but we know
the recipe for success
in political science
and economics.
How do you stop corruption?
Well, you provide
information to citizens
on things like government
contracts and assets
of officials.
You have a free press,
which is allowed
to do muckraking journalism.
You have a civil
society organization
that works with them.
You have anti-corruption
agencies that are independent
and a court system
that's independent.
And over time, you'll see
the reduction of corruption.
None of those
features that I just
named are present
in Xi Jinping's
anti-corruption campaign.
So this is a top-down
campaign, driven
by the party, kept
within the party,
and the party is basically
trying to police itself.
And so that's important
to keep in mind
when we talk about the
anti-corruption campaign.
So that's what Xi
Jinping is about.
He's populist,
he's authoritarian,
and he's nationalistic.
In terms of his popularity,
I would say, I look at it
and I actually see,
if he is popular,
it's for the same reasons
that Donald Trump is popular.
I went another 10 minutes
without bringing up his name.
So the Chinese Dream is kind of
a version of Make America Great
Again.
It's Make China Great Again.
I hate to be simplistic, but
there is a similarity there.
The authoritarianism-- so
Donald Trump and Xi Jinping
are both willing to speak the
language of law and order,
and use the tools of coercion
to try to repress outgroups.
That is a common
feature in their rule.
And then the populism-- so
the anti-corruption campaign
is actually a version
of drain the swamp.
And actually, I think,
in the Chinese case,
it's more authentic
than what we're
seeing with Donald Trump
in terms of a commitment
to clean governance, of course.
So the question is,
is Xi Jinping popular?
And as a foreigner
standing in New York,
I am hesitant to even
weigh in on this.
But my own sense--
first of all, any time we
try to assess the popularity
of an authoritarian regime--
this is sort of one of
the classic questions
in political science--
it's very difficult to
do, because let's say
you could do a survey,
and you ask people,
do you approve of
the performance
of Xi Jinping in office?
First of all, in China, you
can't ask that question.
I do surveys in China.
You're not allowed to ask
this sort of question.
In other authoritarian
countries--
so Putin and other
authoritarian leaders
have public opinion
polling about them.
In China, you're not allowed
to ask about the performance
of any individual leader.
But let's say, even if we
did have that question,
and we see a lot
of people approve,
is it because they
actually approve?
Is it because they've
been indoctrinated
to say they approve?
Or is it because
they are scared,
and they say they approve even
though they don't approve?
So it's very difficult
to differentiate
those different possibilities.
So we don't really know
how popular Xi Jinping is.
That's an important
thing to emphasize.
My own sense, through my
conversations with students,
friends in China,
and other people,
is that he does maintain
a broad base of support.
So people who are intellectuals,
liberals, business elites,
are generally less supportive
of him because of the themes
I've just outlined.
But among the
common population he
seems to be viewed as a
strong leader who is helping
change China for the better.
He's assertive abroad, and he's
tough at home on people who
have been guilty of corruption.
So he does have a
base of support.
So all that being
said, what are we
looking about-- what
should we be thinking
about moving forward for China?
And why was
2017-2018 a big year?
I wanted to point to really
three troubling trends for us
to think about as a group.
The first is that we're
seeing an increasing
cult of personality
about Xi Jinping.
So again, another
cliche or trope
in the study of Chinese
politics-- you'll
see a lot of "Time"
magazine covers or magazine
covers where you'll see
an image of Mao Zedong,
and then it'll be peeled
back, and there'll
be an image of Xi Jinping
underneath or something
like that.
So people keep referring
to him as the next Mao,
or China's next emperor.
There's just a series
of phrases that
are used over and over again,
along with things like dragon.
There's a certain way
people report about China,
which is a little simplistic.
But there is some
truth to this idea
that there is a cult
of personality being
fostered around Xi Jinping.
This is the cover of
the "People's Daily,"
"Renmin Ribao," which is the
mouthpiece of the Chinese
Communist Party.
In red-- this is
not my own analysis.
This was a report in "The
Wall Street Journal."
But they noticed that Xi Jinping
had been mentioned 11 times--
the leading word in 11
titles on the front page
of the "People's Daily."
And he's been mentioned
more on the front page
of the "People's Daily" than any
other leader since Mao Zedong.
So this is troubling
in and of itself.
What's particularly
troubling about it is it
leads to a second phenomenon
which is Yes Man politics.
And so it seems to me that at
the elite level in China today,
to oppose Xi Jinping, especially
publicly, is career suicide.
And so what we're
observing instead
is a lot of sycophants,
a lot of people trying
to ingratiate themselves
with Xi Jinping,
praising Xi Jinping Thought.
Universities are
building institutes where
they study Xi Jinping Thought.
And we know-- this is one of
the basic tenets of government
is that power should not
be concentrated too much
in the hands of one person.
At best, that person
is benevolent.
But at worst, that can lead
to extreme policy making,
uninformed policy making.
This is the vote count in the
National People's Congress
of that amendment
that I mentioned,
the constitutional
amendment where
they got rid of term limits
for the presidency, which
is one of the more controversial
pieces of legislation
to happen in China
within the last 30 years.
This is in Chinese, but the
National People's Congress
is huge.
It's the institution I study.
It's the largest
parliament in the world.
It's got almost 3,000 members.
We see 2,958 people
voted for it,
two people voted against it,
and three people abstained.
We don't know who the people
are that abstained or voted
against it.
It's a closed system.
There's some speculation
that Xi Jinping himself may
have been one of those
people to say, oh, yeah,
people are willing to oppose me.
But to me, this is--
the National People's Congress--
I don't want to get
too much into it,
but all of the Chinese
political system
goes according to script.
The party controls everything.
But even within
these institutions,
there usually is
some opposition.
And what we observe in China
today is that a lot of people
are bandwagoning around Xi.
And I worry about that.
The final trend I thought
it was important to bring up
here of all places is the
increasingly sophisticated
surveillance state
we see in China.
So I mentioned
that China is going
through a repressive term.
What makes it
particularly worrisome
is that we have a
highly-sophisticated
authoritarian regime that is now
using the fruits of technology
to repress its population
and monitor its population.
So this is an image of facial
recognition software that's
currently being rolled out.
It's not national yet,
but it's being rolled out
in different
localities in China.
And so we are nearing the point
where the Chinese Communist
Party, within the
next few years,
will likely have full
information on its population.
So using closed-circuit
televisions, they have--
I've heard the estimate
of 200 million,
but I have heard
that number is going
to rise to 300
million or 400 million
closed-circuit
television cameras
around the country within
the next five to 10 years.
Using those in
combination with AI,
which can do facial
recognition--
and I understand that the
technology is not perfect yet,
but it will likely get there--
that, combined with
social media data--
so as you all know,
Chinese citizens commonly
use an app called Weixin WeChat,
which is sort of like a one app
to rule them all.
Not only is it a social
network, but it's also a way
for people to make purchases.
So the Chinese government, of
course, has a backdoor to that.
So we have a situation where
an authoritarian government has
full information on
the social networks,
the political commentary,
the purchases,
and the geographic locations
of all of its citizens.
And this is the dark
side of AI, and big data,
and this sort of technology.
And it's something, again,
we need to be talking about.
And you all, as
technology leaders,
I'm sure are aware of this.
But it's something that we need
to be having discussions about,
and it's an abuse of
this sort of technology.
In China, I should say that it
seems that this technology is
being described as, again, a
way to preserve law and order.
And it's being said,
oh, this is going
to be used to catch jaywalkers
and other petty criminals.
And again, it's
unclear whether or not
Chinese citizens support this.
There might be a faction of them
that does and says, oh, OK, you
have nothing to worry
about if you're not
doing anything wrong.
But it doesn't take a
genius, or a critic,
or a skeptic to say that
this technology will also
be used to target political
dissidents, protesters,
petitioners, and so forth,
anybody that's causing trouble
in the Chinese system.
I should say that as a
political scientist, a lot of us
do fieldwork in China.
And I was party to a
couple of conversations
in the last couple
of years about--
the one thing we do often
with our interview subjects
is we guarantee anonymity.
We say, OK, we can
meet, and I will never
use your name in
anything I write,
and there will never be any
record of this interview out
in public.
Now that we're
operating in China,
I don't think I
could go to China
and tell someone
that I can assure
that no one knows
about this meeting
because the state is everywhere.
I should also say
that this technology
is being rolled out in a part
of China called Xinjiang.
Xinjiang province
in Western China
where there is a large
Muslim population
known as the Uyghurs.
I encourage you to
read about Xinjiang--
X-I-N-J-I-A-N-G. This is
not my area of expertise.
But there is increasing
evidence coming out of Xinjiang
that these sorts of technologies
are being used to basically put
to a large chunk of
the Muslim population
into re-education camps.
So the level of
repression that's
being used in concert with this
technology is very alarming.
So I wanted to leave
time for questions,
and I wanted to close by
just using this phrase "end
of an era," which is not mine.
There's a book that just came
out called "End of an Era,"
by Carl Minzner, which
does a nice job summarizing
some of the trends that
I just spoke about.
But Xi Jinping is saying
we're at the beginning
of a new era, which
inherently means
we're at the end of an old era.
And to me, it seems one of the
big takeaways of the last year
or the last five years, has
been that the Chinese Communist
Party--
the success or failure
of the Communist Party
now lies in the
hands of this person.
And one of the old lessons
of Communist Party history--
and this is the lesson
of the Mao era--
is that no single leader
should become too powerful.
And it seems to me that this
lesson has been forgotten.
So thank you, I
will leave it there,
and we can open it
up to questions.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
Yes.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
One of the things that I was
thinking about during the talk
was, why is this happening now?
I can sort of imagine
maybe it's Xi's personality
and his strong
leadership, or maybe it's
a weakening of the
existing institutions.
But why didn't this happen
with the previous leader?
What kept them in check?
RORY TRUEX: That's
a good question.
It's difficult to answer.
The common narrative
you would hear
is that the previous
leader, Hu Jintao,
actually didn't have this
force of personality.
He wasn't a particularly
strong leader.
He was not anointed by his
predecessor, Jiang Zemin.
He was actually anointed
by Deng Xiaoping.
So Deng Xiaoping leaves office
and anoints his next two
successors, Jiang
Zemin and Hu Jintao.
So Hu Jintao had a
reputation as sort
of a bland technocrat, a guy
that knew how to make policy,
but didn't know actually
how to command the party.
And so this, in some sense,
leaves a power vacuum
that Xi Jinping has
been willing to step in.
In terms of why now, I think
another thing to emphasize
is that this was incremental.
So there were little moves
that happened along the way,
and they went unchecked.
So for example, so Xi
Jinping, upon entering office,
there was a dramatic
purge of one
of his rivals named Bo Xilai,
where this person was trying
to get himself on the
Politburo Standing Committee,
and there's evidence that Xi
Jinping engineered his very
elaborate downfall.
This would be unusual.
And so that sort
of thing happens.
Then we start seeing the
anti-corruption campaign
unfold.
And over time, he
becomes so powerful,
it's like a
self-fulfilling prophecy.
Once someone becomes
this powerful,
now to be opposed
to him is futile.
So I think that's
one of the elements
too is that the
institutions maybe
weren't strong enough in the
beginning to constrain him.
Thanks.
Here, maybe?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Sorry to bring up
Donald Trump again,
but just a curious
thought experiment--
RORY TRUEX: Oh, great.
AUDIENCE: --because
when Xi Jinping decided
to get rid of the
term limit, I think
that was the most ridiculous
thing that Donald Trump said.
Hey, maybe we should
try to do that.
RORY TRUEX: Maybe we
should this someday.
Yeah.
That wasn't alarming
at all to hear.
AUDIENCE: So my question
is a thought experiment.
So assuming--
that's given Trump's
also having a populist
agenda-- if, say,
Trump manages to get
reelected-- and I
know that culturally the US is
very, very different entirely
from China, but if you were to
try to get rid of term limits
in the US, based on
your understanding
of authoritarian
regimes, what might
be a path of least resistance
for him to go about doing that?
RORY TRUEX: Well, that
took a very dark turn,
this conversation.
And we were already
in a dark place.
So the question is
about Donald Trump,
if he were also to try
to similarly consolidate
power and potentially erode
the term limit institution.
It's interesting.
Right when Donald
Trump was elected,
there was a lot of political
scientists much more
senior than I am--
I'm junior, if
you couldn't tell.
People who have been in
the field for a long time
were sincerely alarmed about
the erosion of democracy
in the United States.
And democracy is something
we take for granted here.
It's been around for
hundreds of years.
We expect it to be
around the future.
But democracies elect
themselves out of democracy.
They elect leaders that have
authoritarian tendencies, that
consolidate power.
So there were legitimate
causes for concern
among the political science
community about Donald Trump's
authoritarian tendencies.
And I think he's time
and time again revealed
that he has a certain
envy, let's call it,
of authoritarian leaders.
He's done so with Kim Jong
Un, Putin, and Xi Jinping.
In terms of this
specific scenario,
my hope, as an American citizen,
is if this ever came to pass,
we would see opposition
among not just the Democrats,
but among the Republican Party.
At some point, the
Republican Party
needs to realize that this
is unusual and unsustainable,
and they need to side with
democracy over the party.
And so I hope-- we've
said that before.
The Trump presidency has been
a constant series of events
where we're all
saying, is it this?
Are they finally
going to oppose him?
So my hope is that we
would see opposition.
I would also say there are
major, major differences,
of course, between the Chinese
political system and the United
States, and particularly the
strength of our institutions,
and the court system, and
the legislative branch,
and the media, and the ability
to have public discourse
is way above what
there exists in China.
So I think the outcry,
the public outcry,
would be enough so that
that scenario will never
come to pass.
That's my optimistic take.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Two short questions.
RORY TRUEX: Sure.
AUDIENCE: What do
the Chinese people
know about these constitutional
changes and specifically
the term limits?
And also, in Xi Jinping
Thought, is there any
mentioning of
Confucianism at all?
Does it refer back to
those kinds of thinking?
RORY TRUEX: Yeah, so those
are two good questions.
So again, as a foreigner, I am
hesitant to ever make claims
about this is what the Chinese
people know and this is what
they don't.
AUDIENCE: But specifically
in the media, has it been--
RORY TRUEX: Yeah.
So I would say
that the depiction
of this in the
Chinese media has been
that this wasn't a big deal.
And a lot of the
outcry that occurred
was among people
like me, foreigners
who study China or
write about China.
And the reason it was
pinned as not a big deal
is because actually, the
position of President
in the People's
Republic of China,
if you actually look at
the Chinese constitution,
it's basically a
ceremonial position.
So that office is not, in and
of itself, that important.
It's important because
the person who inhabits
it is the head of the party.
So that's one reason why it
was deemed not that important.
The second reason is
that there actually
are no term limits on the
position of General Secretary
of the Communist Party.
So that position has
never had any term limits.
There's been a norm
that that person only
stays in power for two terms,
but there was never actually
anything on paper
that prescribed that.
So the way this was positioned,
and among people in China
who were describing this, was
that all this reform does,
all this amendment does is put
the position of the presidency,
it syncs it up with the
position of the General
Secretary the Communist Party,
so now nothing has term limits.
So that's the way
it was phrased.
But for those of us on
the outside looking in,
it seems that this is a very
obvious example of an existing
institution that was designed
to curb excess abuses of power,
accumulation of
power, being eroded.
So my sense is that the average
Chinese citizen is probably not
in uproar about
this, but I think
it does remain a pretty
significant political event.
In terms of Confucianism, one
of the elements of Xi Jinping
has been not just the
nationalism in a foreign policy
front, but a cultural
nationalism, and the Communist
Party as being the bearer of
Chinese cultural traditions.
So Confucianism--
I am no expert,
but there are elements
of Confucianism
that are conducive to
authoritarian rule,
in particular the
emphasis on hierarchy
and the relationship between
the ruled and the ruler.
And so we've seen a
resurgence of Confucianism
and the emphasis on
Confucianism in China,
especially as an alternative
to foreign ideologies
like Christianity and so forth.
So I don't believe--
I'd have to look back.
There's a whole book
on Xi Jinping Thought,
and I couldn't get through
it, to be honest with you.
But I don't believe it's
mentioned in great detail.
But culturally and
politically, it
has been an emphasis to focus
on traditional Chinese culture
and heritage.
And the Communist Party and Xi
Jinping are protectors of that.
Thank you.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My question is about
the surveillance state,
but I'll come through
a detour, which
is in the last question
from this microphone,
you mentioned the big
institutional differences
between this country
and China, and I'd
say democracies in
general and China,
and authoritarian regimes.
Now, all of the world
is going into the world
of new surveillance
technologies together.
And we don't have institutions
surrounding those yet.
So do you think there's
a chance or a danger
that democracies around the
world will follow in the model
that China is developing and
will probably first develop
to the greatest extent, and
that everyone will just sort
of stumble into an
authoritarian machine--
literally a machine?
RORY TRUEX: Yeah, so I have
that personality type that
worries about these
sort of things
and the rise of the
surveillance state.
And Google as a company,
as you of all people know,
is involved in the
collection of information
on normal citizens,
which could potentially
be used by a government for
these sorts of purposes.
So I am glad you
brought up the question.
It's something we need to
be talking about a lot.
And I assume you all are talking
about this quite frequently.
I think in the US, it has
a different flavor to it.
Again, I'm not within the CIA.
I don't have much of a
window as to what's going on.
But it seems that it's
being used, again,
for issues of national security,
and information collection that
can be used by the US government
to monitor terrorist suspects
and so forth.
In China, they would
also argue that this
is about national security.
So the dissidents
and protesters and so
forth are undermining
national security.
So it's always governments using
the lens of national security
to infringe upon
people's civil liberties.
And so it is something I think
we should be concerned about.
And I think the difference
in the US versus China
is that in the US, there's at
least a dialogue about this.
And citizens have willingly
given over their information
because the technology
is so good--
Facebook, Google,
Twitter, and so forth.
The tools are so great
that we willingly
give forward our information.
But I think we are
at a point where
if it falls into the
wrong hands or if you have
a certain type of
leader, even in the US,
this information
could be abused.
Thanks.
I never answered
that question before,
but thank you for asking.
AUDIENCE: Could you
expand a little bit
on the world's
largest parliament?
I know you made a point
about how well it's
orchestrated by the party.
But what's it like
in its daily affairs?
How often does that
orchestration happen?
How deep does it go?
RORY TRUEX: Thank you
for asking this question.
So this was the topic
of my dissertation,
so this brings me back to a
sad, lonely, depressing time
in my life.
[LAUGHTER]
So I'll just give a brief
answer because I could
talk about this for a while.
But the National People's
Congress is China's parliament.
And it has 3,000 members.
It meets only once per
year for two weeks.
So you can imagine,
such an institution
is not exactly a forum for
great policy discussion.
And they sit in a
large room called
the Great Hall of the People
which has 3,000 people.
So often when you hear about
the National People's Congress,
you hear the words rubber stamp.
And there is some truth to that.
So nothing ever
before the parliament
in the history of
the institution
before the full body has
ever been voted down ever.
So if that's not a rubber
stamp, I don't know what is.
That said, so one of
the arguments I make--
I did write a book on this.
It's one of those books
that I wouldn't wish it
on anybody to read it,
but if you're interested--
I have a forum, I might as
well self-promote-- it's
called "Making Autocracy Work."
But the argument I try to
make is that actually, this
is one of those institutions
that the Communist Party is
trying to use to channel
citizen grievances
through their institutions.
So rather than have people
protest on the street
and potentially
engage in violence,
they're trying to create
political institutions
that they control, but
that, nevertheless,
serve some conduit
of information
that the government
can then respond to.
So the People's Congress
system is actually a network
of these institutions.
There are five different levels
of government, and all the way
on down to what's known as
the township level in China.
And there are
hundreds of thousands
of legislators in China.
People's deputies,
they're called.
And so what I've
argued in this book
is that these
people, their task is
to go out, and learn
about the population,
and try to convey
this information
to the central government.
But this shouldn't be
confused with democracy.
This shouldn't be confused
with full representation.
These people are handpicked
by the Communist Party,
and they are not allowed
to cross the boundaries.
So you'll never hear about
a People's Congress deputy
saying, oh, maybe we should
talk more about the surveillance
state, or maybe we should have
elections for the position
of the presidency.
So it's a very
constrained system.
But thank you for that question.
That's the easy one for me.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you very much.
This was very informative.
RORY TRUEX: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I also
wanted to ask you
about the international
affairs aspect of Xi Jinping's
administration.
You talked a little
bit about nationalism
and how the Xi Jinping
administration is becoming
more assertive
internationally, especially
in South Asia area,
the Belt and Road.
Could you talk a little
bit more about that?
And where do you see
this administration--
do you see them
applying the tools
that they apply internally-- the
repression, the surveillance--
outside of the borders of China
through technology, and also
through politics and money?
RORY TRUEX: Yeah.
That's a great question.
So it is a broad
question, because China's
foreign relations are
multifaceted and span
everything from territorial
claims and ambitions
to the economy,
environment, and so forth.
One thing I did want to
mention which I haven't yet
is this idea of Chinese
overseas influence.
And so there's a lot
of discussion going on
in the US Congress right
now about so-called China's
influence operations and the
way that it's increasingly
using some of these tools to
try to shift discourse in the US
and other advanced democracies.
In Australia and New Zealand,
this is a major issue.
We see this manifest itself
in a lot of different ways.
The one trend that I'm noticing
and worrying about is this--
using the market, using the
access to China as a way
to coerce people.
And I'm here at
Google, a company
that has had its search engine
throttled over the years
and now no longer has the
market share it should in China
because of this reason.
So a lot of companies,
journalists, academics,
universities are
facing this decision
of do I play by
the party's rules
and compromise my
business or my values
in order to get access to China?
So this manifests itself
in a lot of different ways.
So academics, we
face pressure if we
write about certain things.
We have a fear of potentially
losing visa access.
In the grand scheme of things,
a visa is not a huge deal.
We're going to be fine.
But it's a
manifestation of that.
Firms-- you might have read
about a lot of US airlines
now have been forced to change
their websites because they
can no longer have
the word "Taiwan"
on their website, because
Taiwan is a sensitive topic,
and it's considered
part of China,
according to the
Chinese government,
and on and on and on.
Cambridge University
Press is an example
that's close to home for us.
Cambridge University
Press runs a journal
called "The China Quarterly,"
which is a China journal.
At the pressure of the
Chinese government,
last year-- or was
it two years ago?
I can't remember-- they
removed upwards of 300 articles
from their website in China.
And the articles were all about
things like Tiananmen Square,
and Xinjiang, Tibet--
sensitive topics.
And this is alarming
because then,
if you're a Chinese citizen,
and you're reading "The China
Quarterly," you're getting
a sanitized version
of scholarship on China.
You're getting a sanitized
version of history.
And that's the version that
the party wants you to get.
So fortunately, as a result
of academic pressure,
we saw Cambridge
University Press eventually
reverse its stance.
But all of these individuals
are facing this decision.
And it's a commonality actually
between firms, journalists,
universities, and academics.
So that's one thing
that's alarming to me.
Another thing that is
concerning is the monitoring
that we used to see
reserved for China is now
being extended overseas.
So there are a lot
of Chinese students
at American universities.
And this is something we
need more research on,
so I'm hesitant to
make a statement.
But it seems, from
what I've heard,
that there are many
Chinese students who
feel that they are under the
same level of surveillance
in an American classroom
than they would
be at a Chinese university.
So I teach a course
on Chinese politics,
and we talk about
sensitive topics.
A Chinese student
in my course might
feel reluctant to say
how they really feel
or what they think about
the Chinese government
because they're worried that
they might be being monitored,
or that information
might make its way back
to the Communist Party.
So we are entering a phase where
Xi Jinping's assertiveness has
now led the Communist
Party to try
to influence discourse and
dialogue in other countries.
And that's a trend that
I am worried about.
Thank you for your question.
Here.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You partially
asked actually my question,
but I want to extend the topic.
You mentioned the influences
going abroad, but mainly
focusing on Chinese citizens.
What is influence globally
with other countries?
And do you see a
possible backfire
and would other
countries trying to--
how do I say-- interfere
with China's government issue
and stuff?
RORY TRUEX: So that's
a great question.
So for a long time, the
party rhetoric about this
was that China
does not interfere
within the sovereign
affairs of other countries.
That was the line.
It's sort of this doctrine
of noninterference.
Leave us alone, we'll
leave you alone.
It's unclear whether we should
have believed that ever,
but it's increasingly obvious
that they do interfere in some
of the ways I just mentioned.
More interestingly and
important to think about
is this idea that the Chinese
system of governance itself
could increasingly become a
model for other countries,
particularly developing
countries, to emulate.
This is the so-called
China model.
And it means different
things to different people.
But it's basically where you
have a system of authoritarian
governments-- soft
authoritarianism,
if we want to call it that,
although I don't know how soft
it is--
coupled with
state-led capitalism.
And China has the record
of economic performance
that is potentially
appealing to other countries.
So it remains unclear
how much they're actually
trying to shift
to the governance
models of other countries.
I have a friend,
Maria Repnikova,
who's a great political
scientist based
at Georgia State.
And she's doing
some work on this.
And she's interviewing
officials throughout Africa,
who are increasingly going
to China to be trained
and to study
governance techniques
from the Chinese system as
opposed to a Western system.
So I think it's still
too early to tell
how much influence
there will be,
but I think it will
likely increase.
On that, I think I'm
actually out of time,
so thank you all for
this opportunity.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.